la séance est reprise si monsieur le
rapporteur veut bien rejoindre son banc
monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur Hugonnet est-ce que vous avez
l'amabilité rejoindre votre banque merci
non je dis ça
j'informe le Sénat que la Commission mix
paritaire chargée d'élaborer un texte
sur les dispositions restantes
discussions de la proposition de loi sur
le plafonnement des indices locatifs
n'est pas parvenu à l'adoption d'un
texte commun
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion de
la proposition de loi relative à la
réforme de l'audiovisuel public et à la
souveraineté audiovisuelle présentée par
Monsieur Laurent Lafont et plusieurs de
ses collègues demandent de la commission
de la culture de l'éducation et de la
communication dans la discussion
générale
la parole est à Monsieur Laurent Lafont
auteur de la proposition de loi pour 10
minutes vous avez la parole monsieur le
président
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues nous commençons ce
soir l'examen de la proposition de loi
relative à la réforme de l'audiovisuel
public qui est à la souveraineté
audiovisuelle permettez-moi tout d'abord
de revenir sur le titre de cette
proposition de loi oui nous pensons que
la réforme de l'audiovisuel public est
une condition de la préservation de
notre souveraineté audiovisuelle dont
chacun perçoit bien qu'elle est menacée
ou tout du moins questionné mais la
réaffirmation de notre souveraineté
audiovisuelle est également une
condition de la préservation de notre
audiovisuel public qui a besoin d'une
profonde révision de la loi de 1986 pour
supprimer les nombreux verrous qu'il a
pénalisent par rapport aux plateformes
nous pensons qu'il y a urgence à agir
pas pour renforcer les contraintes sur
les acteurs français comme cela a
souvent été le cas au cours des
dernières années mais au contraire pour
faciliter leur capacité à transformer
leur modèle et proposer des offres de
programmes sur tous les supports le
paysage a beaucoup changé depuis
l'arrivée de Netflix en 2014 les
services de vidéos à la demande et les
services proposant un accès illimité à
la musique ont profondément modifié les
usages de chacun d'entre nous il ne faut
pas oublier certaines applications de
partage de vidéos comme Youtube et
TikTok qui sont devenus les univers
préférentiels de la jeunesse selon les
données qui nous ont été transmises au
cours des auditions il apparaît déjà
qu'en soirée l'audience de ces sites de
partage de vidéos et supérieure à
l'audience de la télévision pour les
jeunes
la télévision et la radio sont-elles
condamnées à s'adresser aux générations
les plus anciennes et donc à terme à
disparaître c'est la niche d'analyse
pardon de certains acteurs qui se
gardent bien de l'affirmer pour autant
public ce n'est pas notre conviction ici
au Sénat pour autant que nous soyons
capables de prendre les bonnes décisions
mais le voulons nous vraiment à quand
remonte la dernière grande réforme
audiovisuelle alors même que les
évolutions technologiques et d'usage
s'enchaînent à un rythme inédit nous
sommes encore en train de nous
interroger sur la réponse à apporter aux
premières évolutions que déjà les
suivantes arrivent en effet l'apparition
des nouveaux acteurs la numérisation de
l'audiovisuelle sont encore en train de
produire leurs effets et percuter notre
modèle que l'intelligence artificielle
apparaît suscitant de nouvelles
questions et fragilisant encore nos
organisations combien de temps
faudra-t-il avant que les pouvoirs
publics donnent un cap apporte enfin les
réponses aux attentes aux attentes pour
les acteurs qui subissent eux de plein
fouet ces évolutions depuis une
quinzaine d'années plusieurs
gouvernements ont annoncé la mise en
chantier d'une grande réforme de la loi
du 30 septembre 1986 mais tous ont
renoncé devant l'obstacle face aux
pressions des groupes d'intérêts aux
corporatismes aussi et il faut bien en
convenir faute d'avoir une vision claire
du chemin à suivre
réformer la loi de 86 ce n'est pas en
remettre en cause les principes
fondamentaux de cette loi auquel nous
sommes tous attachés mais c'est pas
permettre aux acteurs publics comme
privé de faire face à ces nouveaux
concurrents à la puissance financière
incomparable et qui sur de nombreux
aspects ne sont pas soumis à la
législation française ou européenne
c'est tout le sens des propositions que
je fais dans le chapitre 2 de cette
proposition de loi pour lutter contre
les asymétries de concurrence
cette vision sur l'avenir de
l'audiovisuel et en particulier sur
l'audiovisuel public nous y travaillons
ici au Sénat depuis de nombreuses années
dois-je rappeler les travaux de notre
commission de la culture menée en
partenariat avec la commission des
finances en 2015 qui ont donné lieu aux
fameux rapport de notre de nos collègues
Jean-Pierre Leleu et André gatelin puis
au rapport de nos collègues Jean Raymond
Hugonnet et Roger karucci publiait
l'année dernière
j'insiste sur le fait que ces rapports
portaient à chaque fois sur le
financement des sociétés de
l'audiovisuel public et que leur
conclusion ont été qu'il était
impossible de séparer le financement de
l'organisation le financement
d'organisation et de la gouvernance nous
pensons toujours que ces trois aspects
sont inséparables je n'oublie pas la
dimension européenne de notre réflexion
qui s'est appuyée sur un colloque
organisé en 2018 au Sénat à l'initiative
de Catherine Morin de saillie avec la
participation des présidents de la BBC
de la RAI de la RTBF et de la RTS tous
ces travaux nous ont convaincu qu'il
était indispensable de donner plus de
force à notre audiovisuel public en
regroupant ses talents dans une même
structure en confiant le soin de la
piloté à une personnalité ayant une
grande expérience des médias et en
prévoyant des moyens suffisants dans la
durée afin de garantir son indépendance
le rapport de nos collègues députés
Jean-Jacques Gauthier et Quentin
bataillon n'aboutit pas à d'autres
conclusions ils ont indiqué qu'ils
étaient d'accord à 95% avec notre
proposition de loi
j'ajouterai que les 5% manquants ne nous
paraissent pas être des obstacles
insurmables comme la plupart de vos
prédécesseurs à l'exception de Franck
Riester vous avez choisi madame la
ministre de compter sur la bonne volonté
des dirigeants de l'audiovisuel public
pour mener des coopérations par le bas
notre expérience désormais ancienne des
comes nous a malheureusement instruit
quant à la sincérité des engagements qui
peuvent être pris par les uns et par les
autres et je me permets de partager avec
vous Madame la Ministre le fruit de
cette expérience la volonté de
travailler ensemble exprimée par les
dirigeants d'audiovisuel public n'est
jamais aussi dû que lorsque ce profil le
renouvellement de leur mandat ou la
définition de la trajectoire budgétaire
malheureusement en cette matière
également les promesses n'engagent que
ceux qui les reçoivent comme aurait dit
un grand acteur et connaisseur de notre
vie démocratique et nous aurons
l'occasion d'y revenir au cours des
débats mais des engagements pris lors
des comes sont malheureusement peu suivi
des faits nous partageons pour notre
part le constat du président de la com
roc-olivier Mestre pour qui si les
entreprises de l'audiovisuel public sont
livrés à elle-même les convergences
s'effectueront avec lenteur c'est
pourquoi on ne peut se reposer
uniquement sur la volonté des parties
il est inhabituel qu'une initiative
parlementaire propose de modifier
significativement la loi du 30 septembre
1986 c'est je crois une chance pour le
gouvernement qui ne saurait être accusé
de pouvoir de poursuivre pardon quelques
dessins politiques sachez par ailleurs
madame la ministre que nous sommes
ouverts pour faire évoluer ce texte nous
l'avons déjà fait concernant les
modalités de nomination du président de
France médias nous pourrions le faire
également concernant d'autres
dispositions et je pense en particulier
à la vente des droits de retransmission
audiovisuel des compétitions sportives
ou le soutien au développement du DAB+
ce texte
volontairement n'aborde pas ou
subrepticement la question du
financement néanmoins nous le furons
durant les trois jours à travers des
amendements déposés par les différents
groupes vous pouvez voir à la lecture de
ces amendements madame la ministre que
le prolongement par modification de la
Golf du système actuel d'attribution
d'une partie de la TV a ne sera pas une
évidence au Sénat il le sera d'autant
moins si le gouvernement n'entend pas
intégré la question du financement dans
une vision plus globale qui porte
également sur l'organisation et la
gouvernance
il y a aujourd'hui un chemin pour
préserver notre souveraineté
audiovisuelle et nous souhaiterions
l'emprunter ensemble madame la ministre
un moment où madame la Première ministre
appelle de ses vœux la recherche de
majorité de projets nous répondons
favorablement à cet appel en vous
tendant la main à notre tour
merci monsieur le Président la parole
est maintenant Monsieur Jean Raymond
Hugonnet rapporteur de la commission de
la culture de l'éducation et de la
communication pour 10 minutes vous avez
la parole monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues je souhaite à
nouveau remercier le président Laurent
Lafont pour avoir pris l'initiative de
déposer cette proposition de loi
c'est une proposition de loi sénatoriale
cela veut dire qu'elle est très
équilibrée le caractère limité du temps
imparti à la discussion des propositions
de loi imposaient de faire des choix à
la fois quand au sujet traité et au
nombre de dispositions retenues
comme nous l'a dit un acteur reconnu du
monde des médias le Sénat a démontré
qu'une réforme très ambitieuse pouvait
être conduite au moyen d'un texte ne
comportant qu'un nombre restreint
d'articles
le débat sur le fait de savoir si une
réforme de la loi de 1986 est possible
ou non et clos non seulement cette
réforme est possible mais elle est
indispensable et le plus tôt sera le
mieux
si notre texte a reçu un si bon accueil
de la part des grands acteurs français
de l'audiovisuel c'est aussi madame la
ministre parce qu'il a pu bénéficier du
travail réalisé par votre collègue
Franck Riester il y a 3 ans ce texte est
donc aussi un peu le vôtre
pourquoi sommes-nous tant attachés à ce
texte
c'est aussi parce qu'il permet de
dissiper quelques mythes et de rappeler
certaines réalités sur lesquelles je
souhaiterais maintenant revenir
premier mythe nous entendons encore ce
soir nous entendrons encore ce soir je
n'en doute pas de la part de ceux qui
ont fait si peu pour accompagner les
transformations de l'audiovisuel public
que nous serions opposés au service
public et que notre projet aurait pour
objectif d'en réduire les moyens
la réalité est très différente comme le
démontre la proposition de loi nous
sommes au contraire très attaché à
l'existence d'un audiovisuel public fort
indépendant et s'adressant à tous les
Français
si nous arrivent de formuler des regrets
et même quelques critiques c'est que
nous considérons comme le président de
la République en son temps que
l'audiovisuel public n'est pas
exemplaire ou tout du moins qu'il
conserve des marges de progression pour
développer des programmes plus originaux
pour veiller à l'impartialité de son
information et pour s'astreindre à une
gestion économe des deniers publics
nous sommes également opposés c'est un
fait à la politique du quoi qu'il en
coûte y compris en matière d'audiovisuel
public
mais nous ne sommes pas hostiles pour
autant à préserver les moyens de
l'audiovisuel public à condition
cependant d'utiliser au mieux ses moyens
cela signifie que l'audiovisuel public
doit continuer à se réformer en allant
plus loin sur les évolutions de
structures et en renouvelant
profondément son offre de programme
l'objectif de cette proposition est de
permettre l'émergence de trois ou quatre
grands groupes français des médias qui
pourront tenir leur rang en Europe et
l'audiovisuel public doit faire partie
de ses champions
deuxième mythe la mutualisations entre
les sociétés de l'audiovisuel public
donne satisfaction et il ne faut surtout
rien toucher
ce deuxième mythe à peu de partisans
parmi ceux qui connaissent la réalité
des coopérations menées par les sociétés
de l'audiovisuel public lors de son
audition le président de l'arcome rock
Olivier Mestre a ainsi déploré l'absence
de coopération éditoriale entre les
équipes de France 3 et celle de France
Bleu dans les matinales communes il a
aussi regretté la persistance des
programmes distincts pour la radio et la
télévision pour France Info j'ajouterai
pour ma part qu'il est de plus en plus
incompréhensible de maintenir autant de
rédactions distinctes au sein même de
Radio France et de France médiamonde
tout comme on peine à comprendre
pourquoi à une exception près les
équipes de France 3 et de France Bleu en
région n'ont toujours pas été regroupés
dans des locaux communs
les mutualisations ne peuvent continuer
à avancer à ce rythme et pour changer de
tempo rien de tel que de nommer un chef
d'orchestre
j'en viens donc au troisième mythe le
regroupement de l'audiovisuel public
serait inutile coûteux et chronophage
ce troisième mythe est évidemment le
plus facile à démonter
l'éparpillement de l'audiovisuel public
français est un fait unique en Europe
qui démontre chaque jour ses limites et
pourtant certains noms de cesse de
trouver cela formidable
il est vrai que c'était éparpillement
n'a pas que des défauts puisqu'il permet
la multiplication des présidents des
directeurs des rédactions des
correspondants à l'étranger des sites
internet des directions régionales et
locales abondance
mais qui peut croire à un moment où l'on
demande autant d'efforts que les
Français vont accepter éternellement un
tel laissé aller les appels à la
privatisation se multiplient il n'est
plus possible de le nier et pourtant
aucun compte n'est demandé à France
Télévisions pour l'échec de salto qui a
coûté au moins 80 millions d'euros ni
pour l'audience dérisoire de la chaîne
France Info qui coûte également des
dizaines de millions d'euros chaque
année
nous reviendrons sur le soi-disant coût
de la holding j'observe cependant que
les partisans du statut quo surestiment
sans jamais le chiffrer tandis qu'ils
oublient toujours d'évoquer des
économies considérables qu'elle
permettrait de réaliser
je terminerai en évoquant un quatrième
mythe les éditeurs de programme français
seraient très satisfaits de leur
situation actuelle et ne demanderait
aucune réforme
pour les avoir tous rencontrés de
nombreuses fois au cours des derniers
mois je peux vous assurer qu'il n'en est
rien
qu'il s'agisse de la réglementation
concernant la visibilité appropriée les
événements d'importance majeurs la
production indépendante la publicité le
développement du DAB+ l'impatience a
depuis longtemps céder la place à
l'exaspération quand ce n'est pas à la
colère pour les plus exposés à la
concurrence des plateformes
le Sénat ne peut pour sa part se
résigner avoir un secteur d'excellence
français sombré dans l'indifférence avec
la complicité de tous ceux qui trouvent
intérêt à s'allier avec les plateformes
nous croyons au contraire à l'action
publique et nous formons le vœu madame
la ministre que l'élan réformateur porté
par le Président de la République pourra
également atteindre les rivages de
l'audiovisuel français je vous remercie
de votre attention
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant madame Rima Abdul Malak
ministre de la Culture vous avez la
parole madame la ministre
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de la Commission de la culture
de l'éducation et de la communication
Charleroi Lafont monsieur le rapporteur
cher Jean Raymond Hugonnet mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs
audiovisuel public et souveraineté
audiovisuelle deux enjeux majeurs dont
je suis ravie que cette initiative du
président Lafont nous donne l'occasion
de débattre aujourd'hui
de fortes priorités du gouvernement sur
lesquelles nous œuvrons avec
détermination depuis 6 ans
cette proposition de loi témoigne je
crois de notre attachement commun à un
autre duel public fort c'est important
de le rappeler à l'heure où certains
remettent en cause son existence et
plaid pour sa privatisation
rappelons d'abord qu'à l'issue de
l'ambitieux plan de transformation mis
en oeuvre ces dernières années les
résultats de l'audiovisuel public sont
meilleurs que jamais il s'impose comme
le premier média des Français en radio
comme en télévision 50 millions de
téléspectateurs regardent les programmes
de France Télévisions chaque semaine
Radio France est écoutée chaque jour par
plus de 15 millions de dix heures la
part d'audience d'Arte a atteint un
niveau historique chaque semaine à
travers le monde RFI France 24 et
Monte-Carlo doualia rassemble 260
millions de personnes bien sûr on peut
toujours faire mieux et de l'ambition
nous en avons le développement numérique
de le duel public c'est aussi accélérer
avec des résultats remarquables je vais
y revenir qui s'appuie notamment sur le
développement des coopérations
en 2020 oui le gouvernement portait un
projet de loi relatif à la communication
audiovisuelle et à la souveraineté
culturelle à l'ère numérique ce texte
souhaitait favorisé les coopérations
entre Français et les visions Radio
France France média monde et l'Institut
national de l'audiovisuel à travers la
création d'une holding
la crise sanitaire a interrompu ce
projet mais pas l'accélération des
coopérations cette démarche apporter ses
fruits le média global France Info qui
est devenu le premier site d'information
en ligne en France et le fruit de la
coopération entre toutes ces entreprises
sa couverture quotidienne a doublé en 5
ans sur la proximité France Bleu et
France 3 ont lancé une plateforme
commune sous la marque ici et on
groupait leurs forces depuis 2020 la
plateforme Radio France rassemble toute
l'offre de podcasts du service public
elle est passée il y a un an devant
Apple podcast un podcast sur deux
écoutez aujourd'hui en France est un
podcast de l'audiovisuel public les
entreprises ont créé ensemble culture
prime offre culturelle commune sur les
réseaux sociaux et l'offre d'éducation
Luminy il y a aussi des coopérations
moins visibles dites de gestion mais qui
sont très importantes la mise en place
par exemple d'un club qui permet des
achats groupés ou la coopération en
matière de cybersécurité
ces projets communs reposent sur une
gouvernance souple agile qui permet aux
équipes de définir ensemble les
modalités les plus pertinentes de
coopération projet par projet cette
agilité est un atout pour répondre aux
nouveaux défis car depuis l'examen du
projet de loi porté par Franck Riester
le contexte a beaucoup changé vous
l'avez dit vous-même les défis sont
également devenus plus pressants je
pense à la crise de l'information face à
la multiplication des fausses nouvelles
des manipulations ce chaos
informationnel pour reprendre les mots
de Christophe Deloire de Reporters sans
frontières qui s'est accéléré depuis
l'invasion de l'Ukraine par la Russie je
pense aussi à la place prise par les
plateformes qui ont encore gagné du
terrain depuis la crise sanitaire il y a
donc urgence à accélérer aussi sur le
numérique
dès mon arrivée au ministère de la
Culture en mai dernier j'ai souhaité
poursuivre et amplifier une dynamique
qui porte ses fruits en engageant
rapidement les travaux de préparation
des nouveaux contrats d'objectifs et de
moyens j'ai fait part de ma volonté de
signer des contrats synchronisés entre
eux et sur la durée de la mandature une
durée de 5 ans pour 2024 2028 au lieu de
3 ans précédemment pour garantir aux
sociétés la visibilité dont elles ont
besoin pour faire face à ces défis j'ai
souhaité bâtir ses contrats en
m'appuyant sur des concertations
approfondies avec l'ensemble des acteurs
les dirigeants le duel public français
mais aussi européen que j'ai consulté
les organisations professionnelles avec
vous mesdames les sénatrices messieurs
les sénateurs ainsi que vos collègues de
l'Assemblée nationale avec LARCOM
j'ai constaté un large consensus sur
cinq enjeux prioritaires informations
proximité création jeunesse et numérique
j'ai aussi pu constater l'engagement et
la disponibilité totale des entreprises
à coopérer au service de ses priorités
la profondissement des coopérations sera
donc un axe majeur des nouveaux contrats
et elles ont fait énormément de
propositions très précises sur la
détection des fausses informations les
investissements technologiques la
recherche et le développement la
mutualisation de la formation etc etc
etc pour la première fois un contrat
spécifique signé par toutes les
entreprises sera dédiée aux coopérations
dans les comes avec un calendrier de
mise en oeuvre des objectifs précis des
indicateurs des leviers pour renforcer
le pilotage peuvent être
identifiés un conseil stratégique des
présidents de Lodel public pourraient
par exemple se réunir mensuellement et
se décliner dans des réunions des
membres des Comex sur les sujets majeur
S
la part variable de la rémunération des
dirigeants pourraient davantage dépendre
de leurs capacité à mener à bien les
chantiers de coopération voilà
concrètement comment encourager les
coopérations entre les entreprises au
service d'une ambition forte pour lutter
contre la désinformation pour rapprocher
les offres numériques pour développer
l'offre de proximité pour toucher de
nouveaux publics notamment les jeunes
les coopérations ne sont pas une fin en
soi et leur succès dépend avant tout de
la clarté des objectifs poursuivis un
grand mécano institutionnel ne
m'apparaît ni nécessaire ni prioritaire
je suis convaincue qu'une véritable
ambition pour le diesel public peut
reposer sur des coopérations par projet
sur la confiance dans les dirigeants
nommés par l'arcome et dans leurs
équipes sans accroître l'é rigidité sans
courir le risque de perdre en souplesse
organisationnelle
les travaux avancent très bien et mon
objectif est que ces contrats
d'objectifs et de moyens 2024 2028 soit
soumis au Parlement et aux régulateurs
pour avis à l'automne afin de les
finaliser avant la fin de cette année
changer de méthode maintenant pour créer
une holding dont je comprends que ce
serait une première étape vers une
fusion c'est retarder il me semble des
projets indispensables ces mobiliser
l'énergie des entreprises sur des
réorganisations de structure au
détriment des priorités urgentes une
machine à perdre son temps pour
reprendre les mots de Pascal regarde
directeur général de la SSD dans le
rapport que vous avez publié en juin
2022 qui préconisaient une fusion
monsieur le rapporteur vous indiquez
vous-même à voir je vous cite entendu
les avis de nombreuses experts
auditionnés qui s'interrogaient sur
l'intérêt de créer une holding compte
tenu de la complexité de ce type de
structure qui ajoute une couche
supplémentaire
avec le risque de multiplier le nombre
des décideurs au lieu de les réduire
voilà c'est très clair vous l'avez très
bien dit vous-même la création d'une
holding induirait très certainement une
complexification des processus et des
coûts supplémentaires moi aussi j'ai
échangé avec de nombreux experts et tout
c'était plutôt sceptiques sur la holding
craignant que cette couche
supplémentaire ralentisse finalement
l'élan engagé en matière de coopération
qui s'approfondit et qui s'accélère
monsieur le Sénator Hugonnet votre
rapport s'intitule changer de cap mais
j'ai l'impression que vous avez
vous-même changé de cap entre temps en
tout cas pour ma part je ne serai pas
favorable au dispositions qui crée une
société holding car si je partage
l'ambition que vous portez pour le dieu
usuel public je ne partage pas le chemin
que vous proposez pour porter cette
ambition
la proposition de loi comporte un
deuxième volet relatif à la souveraineté
audiovisuelle c'est une priorité de
notre action et je veux rappeler ici
quelques-unes des avancées majeures
enregistrées depuis six ans dans ce
domaine victoire historique pour la
souveraineté audiovisuelle nous avons
intégré les plateformes étrangères dans
notre modèle de financement de la
création nous avons étendu en 2017 la
taxe sur la vidéo qui alimente le CNC à
toutes les plateformes numériques et
depuis juillet 2021 les plateformes
américaines Netflix Disney plus Amazon
Prime vidéo etc doivent financer la
création française et opérer et
européenne à hauteur de 20% du chiffre
d'affaires qu'elle réalise en France
leur investissement devrait représenter
chaque année un surcroît de financement
de l'ordre de 300 millions d'euros qui
viendra s'ajouter à la contribution
encore majoritaire et bien sûr
déterminante des chaînes historiques
puisque c'est l'un des objectifs de ce
texte je rappelle que nous avons
également donné plus de marge de
manœuvre aux chaînes traditionnelles en
les autorisant à faire de la public
rester segmenté et à titre expérimental
de la publicité pour le cinéma on
assouplissant l'encadrement de la
diffusion de cinéma à la télévision en
leur donnant les moyens de mieux
rentabiliser aussi leurs investissements
dans la création vous le savez monsieur
le rapporteur notre réforme des
obligations de financement de la
production audiovisuelle et
cinématographique résulte d'un accord
politique récent sur la définition de la
production indépendante cet équilibre
est issu de la loi relative à la
régulation et à l'accès aux offres
culturelles à l'air numérique dont vous
étiez également rapporteur de nombreux
acteurs ont signé des accords en se
fondant sur cet équilibre nous ne
souhaitons pas le remettre en cause nous
avons apporté des réponses à de nouveaux
défis qui menacent la souveraineté
audiovisuelle vous le savez les grandes
plateformes étrangères concluent des
contrats avec les constructeurs
d'équipements pour être mis en avant que
ce soit sur l'écran d'accueil des
téléviseurs connectés ou sur la
télécommande notre service public et nos
acteurs nationaux
qui contribue au pluralisme et à la
diversité culturelle sont de moins en
moins visibles et accessibles dans ces
nouveaux environnements c'est pourquoi
nous avons introduit des obligations de
mise en avant des services audiovisuels
d'intérêt général dans ces
environnements la mise en oeuvre de ces
obligations par l'arcome notamment la
définition des services d'intérêt
général est en cours dans la
concertation vous proposez de figer les
choses dans ce texte je suis pas
certaine que ce soit la meilleure voie
comment ne pas évoquer aussi rapidement
la modernisation de la régulation et la
création de l'arcome le renforcement de
la lutte contre le piratage des œuvres
et programme audiovisuel la protection
des catalogues cinématographiques et
audiovisuelles en cas de sessions un
acteur étranger ou encore le droit
voisin des éditeurs de presse combattent
la France apporter avec beaucoup de
force enfin j'ai annoncé récemment à
Cannes les lauréats de l'appel à projets
la grande fabrique de l'image dans le
cadre du plan d'investissement France
2030 une initiative inédite dotée de 350
millions d'euros
qui va faire de la France un leader des
tournages de la production de films
série jeux vidéo de la post-production
des effets visuels et de la formation au
métier du cinéma et de l'audiovisuel il
s'agit là encore de défendre pleinement
notre souveraineté audiovisuelle et
culturelle c'est donc une action d'une
ambition sans précédent en faveur de
notre souveraineté culturelle que nous
avons menée et que nous continuons de
mener d'autres réformes sont en cours
ainsi le gouvernement a engagé une
révision de la liste des événements
d'importance majeures pour garantir
l'accès du plus grand nombre de
téléspectateurs aux manifestations
sportives en particulier féminine je
salue sur ce sujet l'engagement de David
Assouline nous devons aller plus loin et
je partage pleinement avec vous
l'objectif de soumettre les plateformes
numériques au même obligations que les
services de télévision
alors comme vous le savez cela nécessite
une révision de la directive SMA mais
plusieurs États membres semblent
disposer à l'appuyer en attendant le
texte adopté en commission apporte une
première réponse intéressante que le
gouvernement soutient je partage aussi
certaines propositions en faveur de la
modernisation de la TNT la diffusion
herbienne demeure le seul mode de
diffusion gratuit souverain et anonyme
et les chaînes de la TNT portent encore
l'essentiel du financement de la
création c'est pourquoi je soutiens les
dispositions adoptées en commission à
l'initiative madame Morin de saillie sur
la ultra haute définition j'ai moi-même
récemment saisi l'arcom pour permettre à
France Télévisions d'offrir à nos
concitoyens une diffusion des Jeux
olympiques de 2024 en Ultra Haute
Définition je soutiens aussi en matière
de radio le déploiement du DAB plus
cette norme de diffusion souveraine plus
économe en ressources le texte qui vous
est soumis nous paraît soulevé quelques
difficultés juridiques mais le sénateur
Julien barjoton a proposé une rédaction
alternative qui permettrait de les
surmonter
nous aurons l'occasion de reparler de
ces articles et de ce que je n'ai pas
mentionné je veux conclure en vous
remerciant toutes et tous mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs pour
votre mobilisation constante pour
certains depuis de nombreuses années sur
ses enjeux vos travaux votre expertise
votre engagement ont apporté et
continuer d'apporter une contribution
précieuse et déterminante à l'évolution
de l'audiovisuel je me réjouis dans des
battre avec vous ce soir je vous
remercie
merci madame la ministre et avant de
donner la parole aux orateurs de groupe
je la donne au président Lafont
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues nous avons comme vous avez pu
le constater du débuté la discussion
générale de cette proposition plutôt que
prévu et par conséquent je propose aux
membres de la commission de la culture
de nous retrouver en salle 245 à l'issue
de la discussion générale pour examiner
l'ensemble des amendements de séances
déposés sur cette proposition de loi
bien merci monsieur le Président pour
cette information donc nous allons dans
la suite de la discussion générale
donner la parole aux orateurs des
groupes en commençant par Bernard fialer
pour le groupe RDSE
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le président de commission et
monsieur le rapporteur chers collègues
jamais notre société n'a eu autant
besoin de repères claire et innovant
dans la diffusion d'informations de
culture et de divertissement
l'audiovisuel public à cette lourde
tâche de fournir une information
indépendante indispensable à la vie
démocratique et des divertissements qui
doivent permettre la diffusion de
contenu culturels sportif éducatif vers
une population qui en serait éloignée
il doit prolonger l'enseignement public
dans l'élévation des individus au rang
de citoyens éclairés
depuis la loi Léotard de 1986 s'il y a
eu quelques évolutions il n'y a pas eu
de grande réforme qui aurait permis à
l'audiovisuel public de mieux répondre à
la révolution numérique et aux
offensives de grands groupes privés
étrangers qui ont su bien mieux
exploiter les nouvelles technologies
numériques
le rapport sénatorial le le gatelin
appelait dès 2015 une réforme des
missions de l'organisation et du
financement de l'audiovisuel public en
2019 c'est Franck Riester le ministre de
la culture de l'époque qui proposait une
réforme ambitieuse elle aurait été
victime du covid un covidon semble-t-il
puisque n'en sait pas relevé enfin il y
a un an nos collègues Jean Raymond
Hugonnet le président Roger caoutchi ont
rendu en rapport pour renforcer la
spécificité l'efficacité et la puissance
de l'audiovisuel public aussi cette PPL
de notre président Laurent Laffont
propose une réforme attendue et
nécessaire de lieu de visuel public et
de sa souveraineté
elle soulève les inquiétudes et les
oppositions de tous les conservatismes
d'un secteur qui devrait au contraire
avoir l'ambition de s'adapter au
contexte d'avancer technologique et
concurrence qu'impose les nouveaux modes
de consommation culturelle comme on dit
et de recherche d'intégrité des
informations
l'ambition de cette proposition de loi
est grande il s'agit de retrouver une
stratégie et une capacité d'innovation
depuis longtemps perdu
en rassemblant les quatre entreprises
nationales de l'audiovisuel public dans
une même structure les différentes
grammaires se rencontreront et devront
apprendre à faire sens commun
sensible à un développement structurel
de l'audiovisuel public la présente
proposition de loi en temps supprimer
les contrats d'objectifs et de moyens
pour créer des conventions plurielles
stratégiques
en assumant le choix de détenir la
totalité du capital de ce groupement
l'état réaffirme son engagement pour la
pérennité et son souci de sécurité pour
nos médias publics
il est certain qu'une telle proposition
bousculera les habitudes et les méthodes
de travail l'enjeu est alors de
respecter la subsidiarité et de faire
confiance la diversité de la composition
du conseil d'administration permet d'y
veiller
enfin faire preuve pour l'audiovisuel ne
peut se faire sans un travail
collaboratrice avec le secteur privé en
demandant aux chaînes payantes de
laisser une place à l'audiovisuel public
notamment lors des événements sportifs
cette proposition fait place aux communs
et initie la fin de l'égoïsme
concurrentiel
pour ma part si j'ai applaudis la
suppression de la contribution à
l'audiovisuel public qui était injuste
et insuffisant d'ailleurs il est il faut
clairement définir la ressource pérenne
et rassurante promise pour secteur qui
doit être soutenu certes avec vigilance
mais sécurisé afin qu'il s'engage avec
confiance dans les nouveaux défis qu'il
a relevé
parce que cette proposition de loi
reconnaît dans l'audiovisuel public un
vecteur de connaissance de créativité de
critiques de divertissement et
d'enseignement le groupe RDSS se
prononcera simplement à l'issue des
débats sur ce texte que pour ma part je
soutiens
bien merci chers collègues et je passe
maintenant la parole au président Roger
caoutchi pour le groupe les républicains
permettez-moi d'abord de vous remercier
de me relayer quelques minutes pour que
je puisse intervenir madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
Président de la Commission
je vais voter cette proposition de loi
dire que je vais le faire avec un
enthousiasme délirant serait excessif
je le dis d'autant plus madame la
ministre que je pense qu'en réalité
vous allez veiller soigneusement à ce
que son parcours parlementaire s'arrête
au Sénat
ce qui me fait penser que
c'est intéressant pour nous parce que
c'est une manière de vous pousser
peut-être dans vos retranchements pour
dire un certain nombre de choses
mais en même temps
ce ne sera que le constat d'un échec
un échec pour le gouvernement
en 2017 le président de la République
nous avait promis en matière
d'audiovisuelle le grand soir ça allait
être la révolution on allait voir ce
qu'on allait voir on avait paraît-il
l'audiovisuel public pas le plus
détestable enfin le moins abouti et par
conséquent il fallait tout changer
il y a eu un certain nombre de choses
qui ont été faites et le texte de du
ministre Riester n'était pas négligeable
loin sans faux puisque il apportait un
certain nombre d'évolutions pour ne pas
être d'accord avec tout mais il a porté
un certain nombre d'évolutions ce texte
en réalité parce que vous dites c'est le
covid non c'est un peu avant le covid
qui
est parti dans les sables mouvants et
qu'on ne l'a jamais vu
en réalité je pense que
la détermination Elyséenne de faire une
réforme de l'audiovisuel public avait
disparu en 2019 et qu'à partir de là
c'est extrêmement difficile c'est pas du
tout madame la ministre par rapport à
votre propre action les ministres de la
Culture précédent ne pouvaient pas faire
plus à partir du moment où l'Élysée sur
un domaine aussi difficile que
l'audiovisuel public n'est pas
totalement déterminé il n'y a pas de
réforme en réalité qu'est-ce qui se
passe vous avez les partisans par
définition les acteurs eux-mêmes souvent
de l'audiovisuel public ou maintenant en
partie le gouvernement qui disent on va
corriger à la marge
on va voir comment on peut faire pour
avoir ici ou là des rapprochements des
des petites voilà des des petites
évolutions mais on ne touche pas au
système on ne touche pas à l'ensemble
des chaînes on ne touche pas au
périmètre on ne touche pas à
l'organisation et à la structure même de
l'audiovisuel public or quand on a reçu
avec Jean Raymond Hugonnet tous les
acteurs de l'audiovisuel public même
ceux qui ne voulaient pas de réforme
reconnaissez que le système actuel avait
non seulement des imperfections mais
qu'à un moment donné il ne permettrait
plus d'assurer le service public
en réalité qu'est-ce que nous demandons
et je remercie infiniment le président
Laurent de le dire dans dans ce texte
nous demandons un débat sur quelles sont
les missions d'un service public en
France c'est quand même pas un débat
surréaliste que de demander ce que
peut-être ce que doit être la mission de
l'audiovisuel public dans ce pays
deuxième élément quelle structure il y a
eu la réforme de 86 mais au-delà de ça
depuis 37 ans on aménage à la marge mais
on n'a pas voulu regarder en face les
choses et tout le paysage a changé en
Europe dans le monde avec les
plateformes avec la concurrence du privé
tout le paysage a changé
et nous nous continuons de dire on va
aménager à la marge ça ne suffira pas ça
ne suffira plus je voterai en faveur de
la holding moi j'étais avec Jean Raymond
dans mon rapport précédent sur la fusion
mais si ça peut être une étape je la
prends parce que mon navire rien n'est
pire que l'immobilisme rien n'est pire
que de dire on ne bouge pas on ne
changera rien
après nous le déluge on verra bien ce
qui se passe la vérité c'est que ça ne
pourra pas tenir on voit bien déjà les
débats sur la publicité on voit bien ce
qui s'est passé avec les plateformes on
voit bien l'échec de la fusion TF1 M6
avec les conséquences par rapport à
l'audiovisuel public on voit bien un
certain nombre d'éléments on voit bien
des critiques des demandes bon qu'est-ce
qu'on fait on voit bien j'aurais
morigonet le rappeler tout à l'heure on
nous a dit et ça remonte à plusieurs
années vous allez voir ce que vous allez
voir c'est pas la peine de faire des
réformes fortes de les rapprochements
vont se faire presque de manière
automatique le rapprochement France 3
France Bleu ça fait pas mon admiration
tous les jours voilà parce que ça ne
réussit que moyennement c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire alors que ça a déjà
plusieurs années en vrai en vrai pardon
de le dire comme ça les rapprochements
on peut les faire effectivement avec des
réunions supplémentaires avec des
colloques et des conventions mais dans
la pratique si la loi ne fixe pas un
certain nombre d'éléments il ne se font
pas ils ne se font pas parce que c'est
la logique du système on a créé un
certain nombre de chaînes il y a
effectivement un système des
présidentielles des responsables qui
assurent leur fonction et qui en réalité
ne comprennent pas pourquoi on voudrait
remettre ce qu'il considère eux comme un
passage abouti le passage n'est pas
abouti jeudi tranquillement que à mon
avis dans les années qui viennent le
système ne tiendra pas et il s'écroulera
face à la concurrence des plateformes du
système privé si nous n'avons pas une
réforme globale avec les acteurs de
l'audiovisuel mais avec eux ça veut pas
dire sans bouger ça ça n'est pas
possible pour nous enfin et j'arrête là
puisqu'il me reste très peu de temps
juste pour vous dire madame la ministre
et là le président la forme en excusera
réformer la Golf pour mettre
l'audiovisuel public au niveau de
l'Europe ou des collectivités locales
comment vous dire
pas tout de suite franchement personne
n'y croit ça ne se fera pas et vous le
savez le vrai sujet c'est que lorsque le
président de la République dans sa
campagne a annoncé sans contrepartie la
suppression de la redevance il n'avait
rien rien prévu en alternance et nous
voilà tous en train de chercher
désespérément les trois milliards et
demi nécessaire pour l'audiovisuel
public parce qu'on ne sait pas budget
taxe nouvelle taxe nouvelle vous pouvez
pas jeter un minimes monsieur le
Président je vous rassure vous ne pouvez
pas dire on a supprimé la redevance mais
on va créer une autre taxe les gens
comprendraient pas pourquoi vous avez
supprimé la redevance en tout cas madame
la ministre bon courage
merci au président karucci et la parole
est maintenant à Monique DeMarco pour le
groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues les lois inutiles
affaiblissent les lois nécessaires
cette initiative non concertée de notre
collègue Laurent Lafon en est
malheureusement une nouvelle
illustration
le 31 mai dernier suite à l'adoption
d'une loi pour la préservation du
journalisme par l'assemblée de
Californie le directeur de la
communication politique de Facebook
mecta a menacé de supprimer de fil
d'actualité de Facebook je cite plutôt
que de payer pour une caisse noire
écrit-il sur Twitter
depuis une dizaine d'années nous sommes
devenus des spectateurs de la
transformation du paysage médiatique
international avec l'histoire des
plateformes de service de vidéo à la
demande le développement des réseaux
sociaux et la croissance du marché
publicitaire comme source de financement
notamment des compétitions sportives il
en résulte une très forte concentration
médiatique dominée par quelques géants
dont les règles internes ont presque
force de loi
en 2025 le mange le marché mondial de la
publicité pouvait franchir le cap de
1000 milliards de dollars soit le PIB
des Pays-Bas les trois que sont Google
Facebook et Amazon en détiennent
désormais plus de 50% de ce marché cette
position
ultra dominante leur permet d'exercer un
chantage sur les parlements à travers le
monde
en France la commission d'enquête
sénatoriale conduite par notre collègue
d'habitsouline a mis en lumière la
concentration médiatique également à
l'oeuvre dans le pays et également ses
conséquences sur la liberté de la presse
certes on y découpe pas les journalistes
à la tronçonneuse comme un Arabie
Saoudite et on ne les retient pas
arbitrairement sur des motifs
d'espionnage comme en Russie mais on les
licencie on les démait de leur fonction
cela alimente la défiance populaire à
l'enconque de ceux qui nous informent
62% des Français ne feraient pas
confiance aux journalistes ainsi que 41%
des Français s'implanteraient dorénavant
prioritairement via les réseaux sociaux
là justement où les conduits
journalistiques côtoient les
commentaires dépourvus de fondements
factuels noyé dans la masse
d'information anecdotique et personnelle
dans ce contexte notre collègue l'auront
la fond nous propose je cite une
stratégie ambitieuse et globale rédigée
à sa salinitiative afin de stratégie et
d'urgence ce texte propose renforcer des
positions dominantes à l'opposé des
recommandations de la commission
d'enquête déjà cités
pour offrir une nouvelle fenêtre de
fusion par exemple avec TF1 et M6 pour
adapter des règles de droits de
diffusion des événements sportifs
majeurs qui favoriseront Canal+
pire après la suppression de la
redevance l'été dernier la création
d'une holding réunissant quatre acteurs
de l'audiovisuel public constituent
l'hôte pilier de cette stratégie
cette étage supplémentaire nous promet
des années d'immobilisme à l'heure où
l'évolution de ce secteur nécessite de
la souplesse de l'adaptation et de la
rapidité décisionnelle cela va
évidemment affecter les moyens destinés
à la réalisation de missions de service
public cela pourrait fragiliser les
auteurs réalisateurs et les cinéastes
aujourd'hui France Télévisions et le
deuxième diffuseur de films a pris
Canal+ et près de 40% des droits perçus
par les auteurs provenaient des sociétés
publiques
à quoi bon renforcer notre souveraineté
audiovisuelle si cela fragilise
l'exception culturelle française
sans parler du mode désignation du
président de la holding par décret
présidentiel absolument contraire au
projet de directive sur la liberté des
médias présentés par la Commission
européenne en septembre 2022
nous y sommes donc fortement opposés
l'information n'est pas un bien comme
les autres les entreprises de médias ne
devraient pas être soumises au droit de
la concurrence mais à des règles
spécifiques destinées à garantir le
pluralisme et l'indépendance des
rédactions
l'urgence bien sûr ça a été dit et de
réviser la loi de 1986 qui est devenu
obsolète
l'urgence ce n'est pas de rajouter une
strate supplémentaire non budgétisée qui
ne coûterait rien selon notre rapporteur
mais qui viendrait de fait amputer le
financement de l'audiovisuel public
l'urgence serait de rallonger les
contrats d'objectifs de moyens et de
renforcer justement les synergies
mais c'est aussi et surtout de garantir
des mesures pérennes pour l'audiovisuel
public la loft doit prévoir un
financement comme le recommandé
également le rapport d'information
publiée le 7 juin par l'Assemblée
nationale
du côté de la publicité des isomants
fiscaux existent pour financer
l'audiovisuel public la Californie nous
en montre le chemin l'urgence est de
renforcement des moyens d'informer non à
l'instruction budgétaire le journalier
de qualité a un coup mais il est
inférieur au prix démocratique de la
désinformation considérant que cette
proposition de loi ne sert pas l'audio
elle vise plutôt à l'affaiblir nous ne
voterons pas ce texte
des pays pour 6 minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de la Commission ce rapporteur
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
alors on partage tous un objectif commun
qui est celui d'avoir un service public
audiovisuel fort dans le paysage
audiovisuel français et qui puisse
rayonner à l'international c'est à dire
qu'il puisse aussi s'exporter donc sur
l'idée de consolider notre audiovisuel
public nous sommes en phase il y a
évidemment une grande différence c'est
la façon d'y parvenir
à cet objectif c'est à dire sur les
moyens textes propose une mesure qui est
essentiellement la création de la de la
holding et avec une forme d'ambiguïté
d'abord parce que on a écouté les
discours et on comprend pas bien si
c'est une étape avant la fusion qui
n'ose pas dire son nom ou si c'est à
pour toute fin c'est-à-dire qu'on fasse
arrêter là je pense on sort toujours de
l'ambiguïté à son détriment mais c'est
sans doute parce qu'il y a une forme
d'accord et d'entente pour ne pas
finalement trancher et dire clairement
si cette holding est une étape ou si
elle s'arrêtera là deuxième ambiguïté
c'est la façon dont le texte prospère
ensuite a compris qu'il y avait une
position négative du côté du
gouvernement et de la majorité
présidentielle dès lors il appartient
aussi à l'initiat à aux initiateurs de
ce texte de nous expliquer quel groupe
comment ensuite ce texte pourra
prospérer à l'Assemblée sinon nous
pouvons en effet débattre alors
évidemment cette holding elle avait été
proposée en son temps mais depuis 2020
ça a été dit le contexte a profondément
changé d'abord parce que peut-être le
fait de mettre en place cette contrainte
cette possibilité d'une contrainte a
fait bouger les acteurs eux-mêmes et en
février 2023
définir not si il veille on se sont
prononcé pour un document stratégique
unique de l'audiovisuel depuis les
coopérations se sont renforcées cela a
été souligné alors on prend l'exemple de
France 3 France Bleu en disant ça
pourrait aller plus loin plus vite
certainement mais on parle de direction
régionale un on parle de contenu
éditoriaux qui doivent se rapprocher ce
n'est pas parce qu'on n'a pas arrivé on
n'est pas arrivé d'un coup à le faire
qu'il faut renoncer à cette ambition et
donner une chance aux éléments de
coopération qui sont aujourd'hui
installés parce que la question qui se
pose c'est en quoi une holding répond
aux enjeux de l'audiovisuel actuel c'est
à dire en quoi la réponse par un mécano
institutionnel répond aux grandes
questions les grandes questions c'est le
rajeunissement du public on a une on a
par exemple c'est vrai un public de plus
en plus âgé qui regarde la télévision la
télévision de flux c'est le numérique
c'est la concentration de grands acteurs
privés et puis avec l'arrivée de
concurrence étrangère des plateformes
qui ont énormément de moyens
d'investissement on pourrait en trouver
d'autres mais ces enjeux ces défis ils
sont qualitatifs ce qu'il faut surtout
c'est que les acteurs sachent y répondre
qu'on est des personnes de qualité à
l'intérieur de nos chaînes qui savent
faire des propositions ce n'est pas une
strat supplémentaire un mécano
institutionnel qui répond à des défis
qualitatifs me semble-t-il et puis on
l'a dit en France parfois quand on crée
une strate on a du mal à faire des
économies qui vont derrière pourquoi pas
mais la Cour des Comptes est remplie de
rapport qui disent que finalement on a
rajouté un niveau sans que ça vienne
retirer quoi que ce soit au niveau d'en
bas en général parfois on a des exemples
sans vouloir critiquer dans tel ou telle
collectivité le fait que quand on est
rajouté une strate finalement on a
plutôt dépensé de l'argent en plus avec
un risque de déposséder à la fois les
chaînes qui sont en dessous si j'ose
dire et l'État actionnaire qui est
au-dessus en créant une une zone comment
dire intermédiaire et finalement qui
déposait de l'ensemble des acteurs alors
les la question c'est celle d'une
contrainte et qui se passe aujourd'hui
par les contrats d'objectifs et de
moyens donc sans doute faut-il les
consolider les renforcer on peut
imaginer la façon de les rendre plus
contraignants de les évaluer davantage
de tirer les conséquences et de faire de
cette outil un outil équivalent à la
contrainte parce que à la holding parce
qu'au fond le fait de partager une
ambition similaire n'empêche pas de
réfléchir à des outils différents pour y
parvenir et par exemple notamment en
allant plus loin sur la première étape
qui avait déjà été apportée d'une d'un
socle commun au contrat d'objectif et de
moyens et c'est dans ce sens là qu'il
faut aller notamment pour pouvoir faire
face à aux enjeux j'en ai parlé de
certains mais c'est sûr qu'il faut aller
plus loin dans la mutualisation en
matière de lutte contre la
désinformation et des fausses nouvelles
et donc ce qu'on appelle le fack
checking c'est à dire de pouvoir créer
par exemple de rassembler les moyens de
l'audiovisuel sur la lutte contre la
désinformation
sur le numérique bref d'avancer
concrètement de façon pragmatique sujet
par sujet pour aboutir à des résultats
plutôt que une structure qui en
elle-même répondrait et on ne sait pas
comment à l'ensemble de ces sujets je
crains que l'idée ce soit finalement
d'arriver à cette fameuse formule le
mieux et l'ennemi du bien voilà le mieux
ce serait une holding alors que le bien
c'est d'avancer concrètement ensemble
pour faire bouger l'audiovisuel public
merci beaucoup merci chers collègues la
parole est maintenant Monsieur David
Assouline pour le groupe socialiste pour
9 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
monsieur l'auteur de la proposition de
loi et président de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues alors où les grandes
plateformes étrangères les gammes étant
leur gigantesque pouvoir et influence à
croissance sans cesse leur puissance
financière qui les fait rivaliser avec
les États les plus puissants du monde au
point de s'émanciper des règles et du
droit vous la droite sénatoriale vous
avez décidé de légiférer sur le service
public de l'audiovisuel on
l'affaiblissant alors où les
concentrations des médias dans notre
pays continue et que pour l'essentiel
ils sont détenus par 9 milliardaires que
le groupe Bolloré franchit un nouveau
cap dans la prédation et la mise au pas
des médias avec la touche finale mise à
l'acquisition du groupe Lagardère donc
l'édition par image le JD et Europe 1
restructuré pour servir une ligne
idéologique Trump piste à la française
vous la droite sénatoriale vous avez
décidé de montrer du doigt le service
public de l'audiovisuel pourquoi parce
que dans la droite ligne des pressions
que monsieur le rapporteur vous avez
exercé à l'intérieur et à l'extérieur de
la commission d'enquête sur la
constantination des médias dont j'étais
le rapporteur vous faites encore le
relais de ce lobbying d'ailleurs vous
avez annoncé cette loi au moment où les
groupes privés de télévision se sont
unis dans une déclaration commune pour
demander de réduire les financements et
les avantages du service public
d'ailleurs aussi vous avez accédé dans
cette loi alors demande en mettant en
cause les revenus du parrainage après 20
heures alors même que le financement de
l'audiovisuel public n'est plus assuré
sur le moyen et le long terme avec la
suppression de la redevance vous
autorisez la troisième coupure
publicitaire de fiction après 20h donc
pour le privé vous ramenez à deux ans le
délai de revendre une fréquence après
son acquisition alors que c'est la
décision du Sénat sur ma proposition
soutenue par Catherine besoin de saillie
qu'il avait porté à 5 ans pour éviter
les reventes spéculatives vous attaquez
à nouveau la diversité de la production
indépendante vous ouvrez le label SIG
service d'intérêt général aux sociétés
privées sur une visibilité égale à celle
des sociétés publiques alors que c'est
société ne remplissent aucune mission de
service public cela vient s'ajouter aux
petits cadeaux du gouvernement à
l'audiovisuel privé dans la loi du 25
octobre 2021 relative à la régulation et
à la protection qui à la demande des
groupes privés assouplissait des
dispositions anticoncentration
potentiellement dangereuse au regard de
l'exigence constitutionnelle de
pluralisme dans le secteur et j'en passe
pas beaucoup de défense de l'audiovisuel
public des faveurs au privé comme des
petits cavaliers à la demande ici ou là
alors pourquoi vraiment légiférer
là-dessus maintenant à la veille de
l'été quand la situation est si urgente
dans bien des domaines pouvoir d'achat
sécheresse dém ici en danger quand
personne ne vous le demande ni nos
compatriotes ni les principaux concernés
direction et personnelles de
l'audiovisuel public peut-être alors
parce que la situation de ces sociétés
d'exigerait parce que le service public
de l'audiovisuel irait mal et qu'il
aurait besoin tout de suite d'une loi
improvisée ou parce que ces résultats
seraient mauvais ou inquiétant ben non
au contraire il va plutôt bien bien
mieux qu'avant en termes d'audience et
de qualité des programmes de
complémentarité des offres sur les
différents supports des synergies déjà
réalisées par les chaînes TV ou radio à
l'intérieur des groupes synergie à
l'intérieur donc mais aussi Alex
extérieur entre France Télévisions Lina
transmédiamonde Radio France et même
Arte et à quel prix déjà payé par les
salariés avec 900 emplois supprimés à
France Télévisions plus de 4200
équivalents temps plein à Radio France
ces dernières années et des baisses
budgétaires
clairement imposé par des gouvernements
du président Macron
193 millions sur la période
2018-2022 vous proposez donc quelle
nouveauté quelle innovation quelle
audace de créer une holding et vous osez
dire que c'est mieux que c'est pour
faire mieux face au plateformes
étrangères et la concurrence j'imagine
déjà la frayeur dans les bornes d'Amazon
de Netflix d'Apple ou de Google ils
doivent encore être en cellule de crise
pour élaborer la riposte la peur au
ventre j'imagine le vent de panique des
propriétaires des fournisseurs d'accès
du numérique dry pour SFR Bouygues Niel
pour Free soit dit au passage qui sont y
compris fournisseurs d'accès du service
public qui détiennent pas grandissant
des médias privés français qui
contrôlent de façon verticale toute la
chaîne de production de la valeur
j'imagine même l'effroi chez Monsieur
Bolloré demandant conseil à son
confesseur qui ne le quitte plus
paraît-il je les imagine tous tourner en
rond et se dire comment riposter qui
vient soyons sérieux car au contraire je
laissais très satisfait que vous fassiez
porter la tension et la pression sur le
service public et qu'au passage vous
accédiez à leur demande dans quelques
domaines oui soyons sérieux car non
seulement la holding n'est pas le sujet
aujourd'hui pour l'audiovisuel public
c'est direction et personnelles n'en
veulent pas mais en plus la holding ne
sert à rien pour faire face à la
concurrence des gafams et du privé pire
elle créerait une nouvelle strate
bureaucratique une structure de plus
avec des dizaines de millions de
dépenses supplémentaires pour payer des
super chef qui dirigeront des chefs qui
eux-mêmes dirigent déjà des souchettes
elle désorganiserait ce qui a mis du
temps à se stabiliser elle concentrerait
l'énergie de ces sociétés sur une
réorganisation administrative interne au
moment où elle doit être tout entière
dirigée vers l'action à consolider leur
créative dans les domaines de la fiction
comme du documentaire de l'information
et du sport qui sont les valeurs
ajoutées de l'offre en continuant en
direct à investir et former la
révolution numérique et ses prochains
bouleversements avec l'intelligence
artificielle elle créerait des
directeurs des quatre sociétés sous
tutelle d'un président de la holding
tout puissant à nouveau nommé par des
clients conseils des ministres ce qui
mettra à nouveau en danger l'un des
points du secteur par rapport au pouvoir
public un parfum de retour à l'ORTF quel
modernité au contraire s'il y a une
actualité du service public de
l'audiovisuel c'est celle d'assurer son
financement universel pérenne et juge
socialement donc par une taxe
progressive sur l'impôt sur le revenu
directement affecté comme avec mon
groupe nous l'avons proposé c'est de lui
donner les moyens de résister à la
concurrence des gafams et des grands
groupes privés qui détiennent les médias
dans notre pays en légiférant et en
décidant de règle et de régulation
nouvelles dont certaines existent dans
les 32 propositions unanimes votées par
notre commission d'enquête c'est
d'impulser une grande réflexion tant
attendue pour enfin penser globalement
une nouvelle loi
sans celle de 86 percut de rustines il
s'agira certes de réaffirmer ses grands
principes la liberté de communication
mais il faudra repenser les moyens
devenus caduques qu'elle s'était donné
pour remplir ses objectifs et réguler
notre paysage audiovisuel complètement
bouleversé aujourd'hui par la révolution
numérique d'ailleurs il ne s'agit pas là
de protéger de permettre le
développement du sol service public mais
bien de tous les cosystème des éditeurs
producteurs créateurs et salarié de
l'audiovisuel en France privé comme
public qui doit ensemble faire face à
des défis majeurs et les défendre face
au gafam qui ne font pas le tri et qui
risque de mettre tout le monde d'accord
dans le cimetière de l'audiovisuel
français il en va de la démocratie avec
mes camarades du groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicains nous lançons
un appel urgent à cette prise de
conscience une grande illusion fait ses
effets car il y a un paradoxe la
multitude des offres des titres des
chaînes numériques cachent la réalité de
la concentration de la les propriétés
des tenues par un nombre réduit
d'individus et de groupes industriels et
financiers qui ont en plus peut avoir
avec le monde des médias il y a
l'illusion de la diversité alors que les
contenus sont de plus en plus
uniformisés avec l'information c'est
aussi donc la culture qui est en danger
notre résistance doit être d'abord dans
l'affirmation d'un service public fort
et divers fort et divers de ses moyens
de sa créativité de ses valeurs de
liberté d'égalité et de fraternité et
d'une multitude de médias indépendants
qui doivent enfin être soutenus et
favorisés ce paysage là de l'audiovisuel
face à celui hyper concentré verticale
dont les valeurs sont indexées sur la
bourse et les cliques et celui que nous
appelons à défendre avec constance et
combativité c'est pourquoi tout en
saisissant l'occasion de faire quelques
propositions dans le débat sous forme
d'amendement nous voterons contre cette
PPL au pire dangereuse au mieux
inutile
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant monsieur Jérémy Baki pour le
groupe CRCE pour 5 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues tout d'abord je
tiens à dire que cette proposition part
d'une bonne intention celle de vouloir
défendre l'audiovisuel public et de
affirmer sa spécificité souligner cela
me semble important à l'heure où le
service public est attaqué de toute part
l'enjeu des inégalités sociales liées à
la multiplicité des services payants par
abonnement celui de la concentration des
médias ou encore de la désinformation
croissante rend d'autant plus
essentielle d'autant plus urgent de
doter notre pays d'un service public
audiovisuel fort avec les moyennes
nécessaires à son action et des
programmes spécifiques effectivement
nous avons la profonde conviction qu'un
tel service public c'est le signe d'une
démocratie qui fonctionne d'un accès à
la culture et au savoir pour tous et
pour toutes c'est d'ailleurs à ce titre
que nous accueillons positivement la
proposition concernant les droits
téléportifs qui obligerait plateforme à
accéder à accéder pardon certaines
droits des services télévisions accès
libre diffusés sur la CNT et ainsi
permettre meilleur accès pour nos
citoyens au visionnage d'événements
sportifs toutefois nous sommes en
désaccord avec le cœur même de cette
proposition
souhaitant placer les médias publics
sous la coupe d'une holding alors que
rarement l'audiovisuel public n'a été
aussi publicité dans notre pays France
Inter qui depuis 2018 demeure la radio
la plus écoutée en France ou encore avec
la chaîne France 2 enregistrant depuis
plusieurs mois sa meilleure audience au
cours des 10 dernières années votre
proposition risque de ne susciter qu'une
nouvelle inertie des institutions
publiques par ailleurs les coopérations
entre les différentes entreprises de
l'audiovisuel dont appelle à amplifier
cette holding produisent déjà des effets
marquants à travers la création de
plateformes notamment France Info ou
encore ici et maintenant des
collaborations concrètes entre France TV
et Radio France les au-delà de cette
holding puisse nous apparaître inutiles
celle-ci
peut apparaître également dangereuse
d'abord en matière d'indépendance de
l'audiovisuel public puisque s'il n'est
effectivement pas question d'une
nomination directe par l'exécutif il
n'en reste que trop peu de garantie sont
présentés pour garantir une indépendance
effective de ce service public dans les
modalités désignation de plus la
répartition du budget entre les
différentes sociétés de cette
hypothétique holding sera soumise à la
discrétion du directeur général sachant
que l'un des principaux objectifs
exprimés dans la création de cet ondigue
et celui de concurrencer des plateformes
il y a fort à craindre que la radio soit
malheureusement le parent pauvre de ce
nouveau paysage audiovisuel par ailleurs
comment comme vous nous partageons
effectivement le principe de la
nécessité d'une mesure fiscale affectée
car nous considérons qu'effectivement
celle-ci et la mieux à même de garantir
l'indépendance des organismes de
l'audiovisuel et de la prévisibilité de
leurs ressources en revanche rien dans
l'exposé des motifs n'indique quel
serait la nature de que celle-ci mais
s'il est ici question de pérennisation
de l'attribution d'une fraction de la
taxe sur la valeur ajoutée à
l'audiovisuel public laissez-moi mes
chers collègues vous exprimer mon
désaccord en effet d'abord parce que
celle-ci est moins protectrice que
n'était l'attribution à une vraie taxe
affectée puisque son mandat est fixé en
mode programmation des finances
publiques ce qui ne constitue en aucun
cas une garantie de respect des
engagements pluriannuels de l'État en
outre la TVA constitue la mesure fiscale
la plus anti redistributive en faisant
peser les forces sur la propension de
consommation plutôt que sur l'épargne
des avantages en fait les foyers les
plus modestes pourtant le retour d'une
contribution à l'audiovisuel public payé
par tous les Français en fonction de
leur revenu serait totalement justifiés
pour maintenir un lien fort avec les
citoyens garantir la plus indépendante
la plus indépendante possible
ludividuelle public vis-à-vis du pouvoir
public économique nous l'appelons de
nouveau et nous continuerons de défendre
sur cette tribune cette proposition
d'ailleurs
concernant les recettes de l'audiovisuel
public je souhaiterais attirer votre
attention sur cette proposition adoptée
en commission sur le plafonnement des
recettes publicitaires cette proposition
fut notamment motivée par le fait que
les recettes issues de la publicité pour
l'audiovisuel public viendrait nuire aux
entreprises du secteur privé car la
publicité en constitue l'unique
ressources nous déplorons ce choix en
faveur des chaînes privées qui cherchent
toujours une part plus importante du
gâteau publicitaire sans compensation
financière garantie une telle
disposition fragilisera encore plus
l'audiovisuel public à nos yeux si cette
proposition de loi part d'un bon
sentiment et que nous pouvons partager
certaines de ces propositions nous
opposons fermement à cette proposition
de holding l'audiovisuel public a besoin
de retour à une hausse résolue de son
budget qui est passé de 0,20% du PIB à
0,16% aujourd'hui tandis qu'en
Angleterre il dépasse les 0,28% ce
service public a besoin de moyens et non
d'une réforme de sa gouvernance c'est
pourquoi nous voter ons contre ce texte
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant Madame
Catherine Morin de saillie pour le
groupe Union centriste pour 8 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame les
ministres mes très chers collègues
pourquoi met-on en France autant de
temps à faire les réformes structurelles
nécessaires pour nous adapter à un monde
en perpétuel l'évolution je pense par
exemple au temps qu'il aura fallu pour
imposer un cadre régulant et sécurisant
à l'espace numérique dans ce contexte
peut allant je salue la mobilisation de
nos ministres de la Culture successifs
qui ont mené le combat à Bruxelles de la
directive SMA et des droits d'auteur et
droits voisins mais à l'échelle de notre
pays les changements et risques
systémiques induits par les nouvelles
technologies l'accélération des
innovations c'est 15 derniers années
aurait dû pousse c'est clairement les
gouvernements successifs à réagir
rapidement à défaut à écouter davantage
le Parlement en particulier les
propositions du Sénat sur le duo visuel
ce n'est pas comme si d'ailleurs rien
n'avait été fait notre commission de la
culture et ses rapports successifs
jamais eu l'honneur de faire partie on
demandait sans relâche la réforme de la
redevance qui s'imposait elle était
faite dans les pays voisins et
l'indispensable évolution du cas de
législatif est réglementaire conçu pour
le monde hertzien envoie de
disporporation
depuis 2009 dernière grande loi
audiovisuelle pas moins de trois
rapports conjoints aux commissions de la
culture et des Finances ont été réalisés
2011-2015 2021 qui ont pointé le
nécessaire évolutions pour adapter notre
audiovisuel à l'heure du tout digital on
le sait il y a belle lurette que la loi
de 86 est obsolète et que nos règles de
concurrence sont dépassées le récent
échec de la fusion TF1 M6 on est bien la
dernière et concernante illustration
face à la tous puissance des gafams pour
assurer notre modèle de création je
pense qu'il faut vraiment un polo
duvisuel privé fort tout comme un pôle
audiovisuel public fort sur ce point
j'ai toujours dit que la réforme de 2009
était restée au milieu du guet il vous
avez alors pourtant une vraie vision une
juste ambition de s'attaquer à la fois
la gouvernance au modèle économique
ainsi commission de du visuel public
aussi je remercie le président de Lafon
reprenant le plan le flambeau de nos
combats de faire en sorte que France
médias prennent j'ai énoncé dans le
rapport le gâteau là que je salue
également de 2015 puisse aboutir en moi
en partie mais que de temps perdu
franchement alors que Franck Riester
avait enfin pu non sans mal lui aussi
faire inscrire à l'ordre du jour la loi
relative à la communication du visuel et
la souveraineté culturelle son abandon a
été acté en 2020 c'est coupable car ça
nous a encore affaibli venons-en à la
proposition de loi elle se concentre sur
les questions de gouvernance avec la
création d'une holding regroupant en
France Télévisions Radio France France
media monde et l'Institut national de
l'audiovisuel
vigilance sur la radio qu'il convient de
toujours considérer comme un média
spécifique vigilant sur notre
audiovisuel extérieur qui doit être
radio comme télévision confortée pour
porter la loi de la France dans le monde
il doit être une référence et une marque
sécruciale face à la désinformation aux
tentatives de déstabilisation que vivent
nos démocraties face à des technologies
toujours plus pointues et je pense bien
sûr à l'intelligence artificielle c'est
aussi parlant de France médiumonde c'est
aussi une bonne chose je voulais dire
Carter et TV5 reste des entreprises
différenciées liées à la structuration
de leur capital maintenant pour
s'assurer de la réussite de la holding
il faut également que le projet
capitaliste sur les dynamiques déjà à
l'oeuvre entre ces quatre entreprises
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour chacun et
chacune des présidents et présidente
pour les efforts importants déjà
accomplis pour assurer la transformation
des métiers pour mutualiser et bien sûr
optimiser les dépenses pour faire des
gains de productivité
l'autre volet de la proposition de loi
maintenant vise à réduire les asymétries
pénalisant les médias historiques je
n'ai pas le temps de développer mais je
me réjouis par exemple du rétablissement
de l'équité en matière de règles de
diffusion des événements sportifs
majeurs j'avais eu l'occasion de vous
interpeller d'ailleurs madame la
ministre sur les menaces pesant sur
Roland-Garros par le biais d'une
question écrite ayant par ailleurs
toujours milité pour la modernisation de
la TNT qui a encore quelques années
devant elle je suis sensible aux
avancées du texte je remercie aussi le
rapporteur d'avoir adopté un article 14
bis qui impose progressivement la
compatibilité des nouveaux téléviseurs
avec la ultra haute définition une
disposition que j'avais déjà fait
adopter en 2021 malheureusement censuré
de manière incompréhensible par le
Conseil constitutionnel pour des raisons
de procédures je regrette en revanche
que mes amendements relatifs à l'accès
des chaînes de télévision au dernier de
consommation de leur programme et été
frappé par l'article 45 car l'entreprise
doit avoir le retour de ce qu'il a conc
en premier lieu ce partage de données
s'inscrit complètement dans ce que en
plus l'Union veut rendre possible en ce
moment en adoptant très prochainement le
Data Act où est donc on est donc là
quelque part monsieur le rapporteur tout
de même à contre-courant pour conclure
j'insisterai sur la question clé du
modèle économique et de financer
financement abordé à l'article 5 oui et
fixé le principe d'une ressource
publique de nature fiscale pérenne
suffisante et prévisible pour le dieu
visuel public encore faut-il que cela se
traduise dans les faits en loi de
finances ainsi que par une loi organique
en laissant une certitude je suis assez
réservée sur le plafond je dois dire de
la publicité et pourtant je rêve d'un
modèle totalement libéré le problème
c'est que le mode de financement l'autre
Duval public a été fragilisé par la
suppression progressive et insidieuse
par Bercy de la Tosse votez tout de même
par le Parlement en 2009 pour compenser
la suppression de la publicité après 20
heures on comprendra donc que pour
l'heure le financement l'audiovisuel
public reste tout de même aléatoire
périlleux cette question est loin d'être
anecdotique à l'heure où le projet de
règlement européen sur la liberté des
médias étant débat après le constat de
certaines dérives que nous autres
Français nous sommes empressés de
dénoncer en Pologne en Hongrie ou dans
d'autres pays ailleurs et bien le fruit
de midi art a été élaboré il vise à
conforter l'indépendance et le
pluralisme des médias dans l'Union il
serait tout de même paradoxal que la
France ne montre pas l'exemple en
assurant à son audiovisuel la ressource
permettant sa perméabilité et surtout
son indépendance car mes chers collègues
vont attirer votre attention il y a une
vraie différence entre une dotation
publique et une dotation d'État entre
une ressource affectée et une ligne
budgétaire calibrée selon le bon vouloir
de Bercy une différence que nos
partenaires n'ont pas manqué de
remarquer lorsque nous avons supprimé la
redevance et que bon nombre
d'observateurs ont d'ailleurs fait
valoir auprès de France media monde leur
disant que de télévision publique ils
étaient contenu télévision d'État alors
avançons sur les réformes madame
ministre ne leur donnons pas de raison à
ces commentateurs et engageons les
réformes qui doivent aussi se poursuivre
sur le modèle économique et le modèle de
financement je conclurai en disant que
lors de ce fameux colloque évoqué tout à
l'heure en 2018 et enchanté
s'étonnaient quand même que la France
pays de l'exception culturelle soit
toujours à la traîne je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant madame Céline voulait
peronnier pour le groupe les
républicains pour 7 minutes
monsieur le Président de la Commission
mes chers collègues depuis 30 ans le
paysage audiovisuel français ne cesse de
se transformer notre pays est
caractérisé par une grande diversité une
langue tradition de production
cinématographique et télévisuelle nous
ne pouvons que nous en féliciter
néanmoins les nouveaux usages apparus
tant à privilégier les vidéos en ligne
sur les chaînes traditionnelles nous
avons tous une grande importance à notre
service public audiovisuel des chaînes
de télévision publique telles que France
Télévisions et artefrance apportent un
service de qualité
pluraliste et accessible à tous les
citoyens elles ont un rôle clé dans la
promotion de la culture de l'éducation
de l'information et de la diversité
cependant l'évolution des habitudes de
consommation des médias a eu un impact
sur l'audiovisuel en France et à
entraîner une baisse de la durée
d'écoute des chaînes de télévision
traditionnelle ensuite avec l'essor de
la concurrence internationale des
plateformes de streaming en ligne comme
Netflix
Amazon Prime vidéo et disney+ les
téléspectateurs français ont désormais
accès à un large éventail de contenu
étrangers ces plateformes ont rassemblé
9,4 millions d'utilisateurs quotidiens
en 2022 cela crée une concurrence et un
défi pour l'industrie audiovisuelle
française qui doit rivaliser pour
attirer et fidéliser son public face à
ces évolutions la puissance publique est
demeurée jusqu'à présent en retrait
pénante à réformer un cadre législatif
posé en 1986 pour réguler un univers
strictement national à une époque où
Internet n'existait pas
il est clair que nous devons renforcer
l'audiovisuel public et notre
souveraineté audiovisuelle par une
stratégie ambitieuse et globale pour
cela deux piliers ont été ciblés le
regroupement de l'audiovisuel public
respectant l'identité de ces différentes
composantes et une révision
significative de la loi du 30 septembre
1986 tel est l'objectif de la
proposition de loi de notre collègue
Laurent Lafont un objectif que nous
partageons amplement je souhaite
remercier également le rapporteur Jean
Raymond Hugonnet pour l'ensemble du
travail réalisé mes chers collègues en
regroupant France Télévisions Radio
France France médiumonde et Lina par la
création d'une société holding France
media nous assurons leur compétitivité
leur développement stratégique au niveau
européen et international tout en
veillant à la cohérence et à la
complémentarité de leurs offres de
programmes
de cette PPL très attendue depuis le
rapport de nos collègues le lieu et
gatolin et plus récemment en 2022 de nos
collègues Roger karucci et Jean Raymond
Hugonnet et de permettre d'appréhender
l'évolution clé du secteur audiovisuel a
l'air du numérique cette PPL a un
objectif clair renforcer la qualité de
la mission de service public de
l'audiovisuel français ainsi que ça
souveraineté dans ce contexte dans le
contexte géopolitique actuel l'enjeu est
de garantir à nos concitoyens une
information de qualité tout en limitant
aussi contre les fake news un véritable
enjeu mutualiser les forces de ces
entreprises sera donc synonyme de
richesse médiatique culturelle mais
aussi source de gains économiques il
apparaît cohérent de vouloir rassembler
des entreprises qui au nom de leur
mission de service public partage les
mêmes ambitions et des projets
industriels similaires
mais attention cette mutualisation n'est
pas synonyme de concurrence interne elle
a bien pour objectif de mutualiser les
logistiques et les investissements afin
de garantir un contenu gratuit et
qualitatif ce point est fondamental
prenons l'exemple de Lina cette grande
institution est freinée dans ses
relations avec les autres entreprises à
cause de son statut juridique au sein de
la holding France media elle gagnera en
flexibilité et en efficacité de plus
elle pourra prendre en charge la
conservation des archives audiovisuelles
diffusées de manière
délinéarisées par les autres sociétés et
les futurs filiales de la holding en ce
qui concerne France médiamonde dont les
journalistes et le réseau de
correspondants offrent en 21 langues une
information essentielle d'ouverture sur
le monde et sur la diversité des
cultures et des points de vue je
souhaite le souligner surtout dans le
contexte géopolitique actuel l'adoption
de la proposition de loi permettra
d'augmenter les synergies avec les
autres chaînes publiques et ainsi
accroître ses compétences à
l'international
cette PPL est aussi une proposition qui
reconnaît l'importance de l'innovation
et des nouvelles technologies dans le
paysage audiovisuel elle encourage la
coopération entre les acteurs publics et
privés pour favoriser l'émergence de
nouveaux formats et de nouvelles
expériences pour les téléspectateurs
cela permet à l'audiovisuel public de
rester pertinent et attractif dans un
environnement médiatique en constante
évolution elle elle mérite d'aborder
enfin la question cruciale de son
financement surtout après la suppression
de la redevance TV en 2022 en réformant
la cape nous garantissant un financement
pérenne et équitable sans peser
excessivement sur les contribuables il
est essentiel que chaque euro investit
dans nos médias publics servent
réellement à la promotion de notre
culture de notre histoire de nos valeurs
en outre cette loi garantie que les
ressources nécessaires seront
disponibles pour soutenir la production
de contenu de qualité la modernisation
des infrastructures et le développement
de nouveaux formats
en donnant davantage d'autonomie
financière à nos médias publics cette
PPL garantit donc une information
objective et équilibrée cependant elle
ne s'arrête pas à la création d'une
holding elle souhaite aussi encadrer la
concurrence étrangère qui part manque
législatif ne prenait pas en compte les
évolutions concurrentielles
audiovisuelles et numérique un
manquement législatif qui se transforme
en concurrence déloyale pour les
entreprises publiques et privées
françaises et qui impose des règles qui
ne sont pas imposées à leur concurrence
étrangers
les asymétries entre les chaînes et les
plateformes numériques seront
drastiquement réduites c'est un point
capital l'industrie audiovisuel
française ne sera plus injustement
pénalisée pour un pleinement investir
les marchés émergents pour conclure mes
chèques mes chers collègues cette PPL
est l'occasion de
réaffirmer notre attachement à la
souveraineté audiovisuelle française
deuxièmement renforcer la mission de
l'audiovisuel public français face à la
désinformation et au contexte
géopolitique mondial perturbé enfin
définir une vraie vision pour
l'audiovisuel à partir d'orientation
stratégique claire tout en veillant à la
cohérence et à la complémentarité des
offres de programmes au service des
Français en gros le réformé pour toutes
ces raisons vous l'aurez compris notre
groupe votera la proposition de loi de
Laurent Lafon je vous remercie
merci chers collègues dernier orateur
inscrit dans la discussion générale la
parole est à notre collègue verzelen
pour les indépendants pour 5 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le Président de la Commission
monsieur le rapporteur
l'audiovisuel français est organisé par
la loi dite Léotard du 30 septembre 86
et le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est
qu'il s'en est passé des choses depuis
de nouveau concurrents sont apparus les
grandes plateformes ont complètement
changé les règles du jeu de nouveau
modèle de consommation se sont fait jour
les tablettes sont arrivées et avec tous
ces bouleversements notre cadre
juridique et donc et législatif est
totalement dépassée nous remercions
l'auteur et le rapporteur et je veux
saluer le nom de la proposition de loi
réformer l'audiovisuel public et
garantir la souveraineté audiovisuelle
la télévision et la radio font partie de
la vie quotidienne des Françaises et des
Français elle participe j'ose le mot a
créé un socle commun elles sont un
puissant vecteur culturel délivrer une
information de qualité ça coûte cher ça
peut être copié instantanément et il n'y
a aucun droit d'auteur rémunéré
la souveraineté audiovisuelle donc doit
permettre aux médias nationaux de
délivrer une information de qualité
vérifiée fiable et objectif la
souveraineté c'est aussi protégée
soutenir et encourager la production
culturelle française
nous en sommes tous convaincus je l'ai
dit il est urgence de réformer la loi de
86 nous nous appuyons aujourd'hui sur
les travaux des sénateurs gatelins et
Leleu de leur rapport ils avaient
précisé les contours de la société
effetière le ministre Riester s'en était
inspiré par la suite malheureusement le
projet de loi annoncé a fait les frais
de la crise du covid de la covid
la création de la société de tête
proposée par ce texte va dans le bon
sens il s'agisse à été dit de regrouper
les forces de l'audiovisuel public une
entité visible cohérente et identifiée
qui regroupera France Télévisions Radio
France France média Elina
cette structure doit être la plus souple
la plus complémentaire la plus réactive
et la plus mutualisée possible le moins
que l'on puisse dire c'est que le défi
est de taille
bâtir une nouvelle société une nouvelle
entité pardon ce sera très utile
et pour en faire quoi
évidemment ce n'est pas aux politiques
de décider de la grille des programmes
mais c'est au législateur de poser un
cadre pour garantir la qualité de
l'information la diversité la créativité
culturelle pour permettre la diffusion
de grands événements sportifs
l'audiovisuel public doit représenter
toutes les sensibilités et toutes les
opinions toutes les sensibilités et
toutes les opinions chaque Français doit
pouvoir s'y reconnaître dans ce texte la
question de la publicité est abordée
néanmoins nous ne sommes qu'au début
d'un long débat comme beaucoup je
comprends l'argument qui consiste à
expliquer claudiovisuel public ne peut
pas fonctionner sur le même modèle
économique et avec les mêmes enjeux les
mêmes priorités que les chaînes privées
mais enfin restons pragmatique si c'est
pour que les annonceurs se détournent
sur d'autres formes de médias et qu'à la
fin on demande une participation
évidemment supplémentaire à l'état je
suis pas complètement certain qu'on se
rende collectivement un grand service et
enfin le débat arrivera j'imagine
quelques mots sur l'article 13 les
producteurs indépendants français
comptent parmi les tous meilleurs au
monde soyons vigilants à ne pas remettre
en cause leur dynamisme et leur
développement en touchant à la relation
entre diffuseurs et éditeurs les élus du
groupe sont très attachés au maintien et
au renforcement des émissions locales et
régionales elle représente autant de
relais d'informations qui font le
quotidien des territoires et leurs
habitants les journalistes doivent
continuer à décrypter les actualités de
terrain de la même manière notre
audiovisuel public doit être le relais
des territoires d'outre-mer
l'audiovisuel public doit être un repère
un modèle et un exemple il doit
continuer d'être une ouverture sur le
monde sur la culture sur la société
notre rôle à tous ici et de garantir sa
singularité sur le long terme en
proposant un cadre juridique stable et
pérenne permettent de réduire les
asymétries qui pénalisent nos acteurs de
l'audiovisuel qu'il soit public ou privé
d'ailleurs ce texte est un bon signal il
démonte notre attachement et notre
préoccupation concernant l'audiovisuel
public français pour ces raisons le
groupe Les Indépendants votera cette
proposition de loi je vous remercie de
votre attention
merci chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président de la Commission
vous n'avez pas prévu une commission
sandwich non c'était juste pour savoir
combien de temps je devais suspendre
parce que comme vous avez un bon moment
de commission ça risque d'être assez
long
monsieur le Président je pense qu'on a à
peu près pour une heure de réunion de
commission alors nous reprendrons
seulement à 21h30 je vais suspendre la
séance elle sera reprise à 21h30 pour la
suite de l'examen de ce texte la séance
est suspendue
[Musique]